sean i'm hoping we can go to page one of
your script for a california christmas
and i'm curious what you like about the
opening scene of the movie
which is page one of course yeah so
uh the opening is obviously it's meant
to establish
joseph's character played by josh
wickard and
he's kind of living this playboy
lifestyle big city
wealthy obviously he's got
someone in bed and uh
you know he's young and he's kind of
using his his
uh obviously his status to uh
kind of live carefree in that way so
basically the point of it is to set up
his character
and and for his arc throughout the story
because obviously he needs to grow um
he's not the best of guys
at this point um so it's really i think
it
helps illustrate that point it sets up
who he is
and the journey he's gonna have to go on
whether he likes it or not
is basically is is the idea obviously
you won't know all of that while seeing
this first scene but
it sets it up of who he is and where he
is at
at this point in his life and he's not a
total jerk he offers to buy the woman
room service yeah so you got to give him
some props but
so yeah yeah again i think
those little details is that we don't
want people to just completely hate him
right off the bat right uh and we did
have some other things early in early
versions and stuff that we're like yeah
that might make him too much of a jerk
you know
certainly there's an argument there that
he's still a jerk but
you know what i'm saying like he has to
have some underlying
qualities and redeemable uh pieces that
that
you want to see him go on a journey of
growth and
self-growth and and becoming uh
hopefully a better
person so before we meet joseph the main
character we have this
aerial shot can we talk about the
establishing image yes the very first
shot is kind of coming up off the
off the water and revealing san
francisco which is
uh you know that's where he is and where
his
family business is um so kind of just
establishing that whole the bay area and
the big city and the
in the the hustle and bustle of city
life because it
is a uh obviously stark contrast to the
ranch
that he later goes to and ends up
spending a lot of time
and we also did some interesting things
in color there so
the city life has has a little bit
cooler of tones to them and when we go
to the ranch
uh everything becomes a little bit
warmer and and
earthier uh in the tones so
that's like a little you know kind of
little details that we pay attention to
when we're making it probably
most people will never notice it but
even with that opening shot we wanted
the color palette of it to be feel
cooler in in tone
uh versus the later part of the movie
and also too he leaves kind of like one
woman in a hotel room
and then as he leaves he kind of flirts
with a desk
clerk or something and yeah you see her
sort of
not not unprofessionally but you so it
already sets him up to be sort of this
casanova
type correct yes yeah he's definitely
got that air about him and
and uh you get the sense that uh you
know
he doesn't know a lot she doesn't know a
lot it's that hashtag best life thing
right he's living his best life but you
know anyways
obviously there's more to it than that
and and at his core
he's he's uh searching for more
sure sure um what do you think the hook
is of the first page that makes
people want to keep reading it goes
beyond just the first page i guess but
the hook of the first page is is is
really the
the kind of setting and the character
like for me when i read it
i wanted to know more about him you know
so it's really like
why is he this way like what makes him
uh
and especially kind because he's kind of
outright
just turns the girl down for a second
date like right there
makes you go well that's audacious like
what like what is his story
so hopefully that's the hook that was
for me when i read it
because uh i didn't write this lauren
swicker didn't
and when i was sent it that's what
grabbed me right away
and i think she says kind of like i'll
call you or whatever and she's and she
says no you want yeah exactly
that little piece right there i'm like
okay yeah
and and the fact that he can get away
with that i think there's probably
plenty of people go well i wouldn't be
able to get away with that or you know
you know those kinds of things uh uh it
makes it intriguing and
and and of course the you see that the
relationship walking through the hotel
lobby
the people like him you know and he's
he's got that thing about him his charm
is charisma
um uh always makes it more interesting i
think even in the back of my head i'm
was even initially you know even right
away thinking
oh he's gonna have some lessons to learn
you know what i mean like there's
there he's probably going to have to go
on a journey
you know and sorry he's brought in to be
and i hope this isn't spoiler to be like
a honey plot
to kind of like infiltrate and and
seduce someone that he needs a signature
from so basically his his company and
his
mother who runs the company they haven't
been able to get this
uh the owners of this ranch to sell
which they need to build a
shipping facility uh for their
corporation
uh their their business and so his mom
decides
that her son basically doesn't really do
anything
you know he's got a title and works at
the company but what does he actually do
so
she recognized he has a certain skill
and and it is a younger woman who
owns the ranch and so she says let's put
your actual skills to use
go out there and get this girl to sell
you know get this woman young woman to
sell and so
i think he thinks he's gonna be able to
waltz in there and and get his way
and and get the the the yes that he
always hears
um and uh and uh
i can say it doesn't go as as he had
planned
sure and his ark falls from there yeah
is there some case of missing missing
identity as well
uh or misidentity that that not missing
a
misidentity that that happens for him as
well in there
um that kind of starts him down a
totally different journey that that he
thought he was going to be going on
so looking back on it now what mistakes
do you think
were there in the first page or was this
the actual shooting script
and there were no mistakes oh uh well
this yeah this is definitely not the the
first version of the script
for sure so this is this is a
closer to the shooting i can't remember
if what i sent you is the actual
shooting shooting one
and gosh it's hard to remember if if
there was
i think there there was more time taken
in
in earlier drafts which i think it took
too long to get to those pieces
and it is of course not even just the
first page but
but that was part of it so i think it
got more refined
and kind of picked the moments that
actually mattered to
to convey the the message that we're
trying to convey
is this still the opening of the movie
yes this is still the opening of the
movie
so yeah it uh it stayed and
obviously i think it's important again
because we have to establish
our our character's journey
you know his character so joseph and
also cali they both have
their journeys um and they kind of you
know their journeys
intersect and that's what they they help
each other on their journey
so that's kind of the that's the you
know
uh age-old kind of love
twist there their their uh their
journeys intersect and of course they
need each other to
to kind of uh complete their journey